anastasiya anger guard has converted her
parking spot in an underground garage in
Moscow into a storage space
she's coordinating donations for doctors
treating coronavirus patients things
like disinfectant kettles disposable
plates and utensils and protective gear
here because without this we cannot
believe right now yeah yeah so here is
it laughs here the main goal here is to
say thank you to the doctors because I
really appreciate everything that they
are doing right now that they are
fighting every day in order to we live
in a healthy world and you know we just
get back to our common life despite a
lockdown in Moscow anastacio Engle guard
wants to ensure her donations reach
doctors as quickly as possible
there are now eight Moscow hospitals
treating coronavirus patients and a new
hospital with 500 beds is being
completed but until it's operational the
majority of patients are being treated
here in coma naka at the Capitals
outskirts as well as needing protective
clothing medical staff also have to eat
Anastacio succeeded in getting a canteen
kitchen quickly on board it was already
producing up to 10,000 ready-to-eat
meals with fresh vegetables for regular
clients at Anastasia's request they are
also now delivering 650 freshly made
meals to doctors and nurses in Moscow
every day for free
which Danskin we consider it our duty to
help the doctors they bear the most
responsibility right now we're making
special finger food for them so that
they can eat quickly and get back to
their patients word of Anastasia's
initiative has spread throughout Moscow
she's managed to convince more than 40
companies and organizations to donate
goods for me this is a good sign because
it's showing how important is to be
together to be connected and how easy to
do this and this is probably it's bad to
say that but it's probably a good side
of this epidemia because this means that
people can be still very connected no
one knows when Russia's coronavirus
epidemic will peak but for Anastasia
anger guard it's clear that her help is
needed now more urgently than ever
okay let's go over to Moscow now we're
your initiator the author of the report
you just saw is standing by hi Gary how
many cases have been confirmed in Russia
and how many people have died from kovat
19 well the situation christine is very
serious for russia the country is a few
weeks behind to europe in terms of new
infections there are currently more than
17,000 people infected with the corona
virus 130 patients died at least that
the official number nobody can really
say how high the real number is another
worrying thing is that 85 percent of all
new infections are people under 65 and
most of the infected people live here in
Moscow Moscow hospitals are running out
of space there have been videos going
around on social media of dozens of
ambulances queuing in front of some
emergency rooms although the authorities
are doing a lot experts warn that Russia
is far from reaching its peak in fact
Moscow's mayor Sergei Sobyanin has said
we are only at the hood of the mountain
how has the Russian government responded
to the crisis is the public health
system prepared nationwide
yeah well there are now several
hospitals in Moscow that have been repro
filed for corona patients unfortunately
Cristina's there are also cases of
infections among doctors and when that
happens the whole Hospital has to close
immediately but Russia seems to be a
long way from Spanish Italian or let's
say American up conditions this
situation appears to be under control
surfer but the problem is not so much
Moscow but the region's medical care in
the countryside is sometimes a
catastrophic and often underfunded my
mother lives for example in Volgograd
and in the south of Russia and she had
to go to the hospital to this two years
ago I visited her there and I have to
say I really don't wish those conditions
and anyone Yuri lockdowns are in place
in Moscow and other cities has the
Russian public been adhering to the
restrictions well the Russians have been
in so-called self-isolation prescribed
by President Putin for several weeks
until the end of April that means that
everyone who doesn't have to go out must
stay at home people can go out for
example to buy food to go to the
pharmacy or take out of the trash shops
are closed and many companies aren't
working trains and buses are running but
they are almost empty and by the way
from Wednesday this week there will even
be electronic passes for Cal journalists
and travel on public transportation and
'muslim anyone who wants to leave the
house has to get an electronic code and
get permission from the city every time
so we'll see how that we will be working
in the coming days but the mood is
peaceful and calm so far that's your
ratio in Moscow thank you